today we're talking about how halo
infinite's co-op is playable because of
a glitch as well as some halo tv series
news
halo infinite's co-op campaign isn't
officially coming until around the end
of the game's first season in may 2022
but that hasn't stopped a number of
players from enabling the mode anyway
though it seems doing so may put your
game saves at risk as spotted on the
halo subreddit someone has managed to
glitch their way into split screen
campaign co-op we've managed to
replicate this ourselves using
instructions that have since been shared
online confirming that it does indeed
work on twitter user noble actual posted
instructions on how to replicate the
glitch along with a short clip clearly
showing co-op working albeit with a
number of caveats for starters player 2
has no hud the game's forward operating
bases are completely busted and if
either player dies the game locks up
trying to enable co-op may also break
your game saves with noble actual
stating their saves eventually refused
to load after hours of trying to
reproduce the glitch another user
halo.api
also confirmed that using the co-op
glitch broke their saves forcing them to
delete them 343 has previously stated
that halo infinite's co-op campaign is
playable internally but the reason for
the mode not making its way into halo
infinite at launch is it requires
additional polish before it's ready for
prime time now that this glitch is out
in the open it's unclear if 343 will
look to update the game so that this
unofficial and admittedly broken version
of co-op is no longer playable
in other halo news the upcoming tv
series will not play around with any of
the established canon and will instead
tell its own story in what it calls the
quote silver timeline 343 industries
head of transmedia kiki wolfkill
explained that the creation of an
entirely new timeline allowed for a halo
story that didn't interfere with the
canon of the video game series during an
interview wolfgall said quote we're
referring to this as the halo silver
timeline as a way of differentiating it
from the core cannon and both protecting
core cannon and protecting the
television story and by that i mean
being able to give ourselves the chance
to evolve both and for both to be what
they need to be for their mediums
without colliding with each other the
halo series will launch on paramount
plus in 2022 is being produced by steven
spielberg's ambulant television and
stars pablo schreiber as master chief
switching gears to stalker 2 and it's
nft drama on december 15th gsc gameworld
developer of stalker revealed its
partnership with d-market to create a
metaverse for the franchise well that
news didn't sit well with fans and the
dev quickly pulled the plug on their
plan the gsc gameworld team issued a
message that said quote based on the
feedback we received we've made a
decision to cancel anything nfc related
in stalker 2. the interests of our fans
and players are top priority for the
team we're making this game for you to
enjoy whatever the cost is if you care
we care too prior to going back on their
plan gsc gameworld stressed that none of
the items offered would provide players
with an advantage in game and wouldn't
be required to play all of stalker 2's
content not sure what nfts are and why
so many people don't want them in games
well we made a video about it so check
that out for some useful information and
to see more of my face if you're into
that
but all right if you need me i'm gonna
go see spider-man and then binge the
witcher season 2 and then play some halo
let me know what you're getting into
[Music]